[Music]
not
[Music]
everybody happy friday i'm so happy to
see you my god it's been a crazy week
but
here we are it's friday and we're going
to be doing another episode of
logo redesign let's jump right into the
deck here
okay we're going to be taking on logos
that you love or logos that you
love to hate this is redesign and today
we have omar returning it's omar salmond
and
omar salman and he's from turkey and
this is some of his newer work that he
just shared with me so it's looking
really good
i see the progress that you're making
here young man and we're going to be
doing
we're taking on the ing logo right what
is this going to look like
so before we get into that i have to ask
you omar
why did you choose the ing logo of all
things what's going on with you
first thank you chris for having me
again the show
before i understood why i chose ing logo
i want to talk a little bit about
rebranding
okay so what's the
rebrand well first let's start by
defining
these three trims brand and branding
and brand identity because most
people they confuse the meaning and use
them incorrectly so i will try
explaining quickly and
easily according to
martin newmar the bra a brand is a
person got feeling
about any products or service or company
and the brand it is the process of
building
influence on the customer got feeling
and re-brand
a contact with the martin numero and
asked him
about the definition of rebrand and he
said
rebranding is just the revision of an
existing brand but it does have to
extend
deep into the roots of company propose
and its
strategy it can't simply be re-message
or redesign
on a surface level
most reason of free branding
is um one when your brand
does doesn't reflect your business your
your business grow with time whether
your client base ex
bands your contains
other customer say gets meant or you
go international or you added
a production line production line into
your
factory also in same cases you may even
acquire small companies to be added
under your
business umbrella with main your
name must change to fit your new size
and you are undergoing
measure or acquisition and
when you need to disconnect from a
negative
image in some cases your brand image
may be totally corrupted your
audience hates you because of a brand
attacked or any other reason such a
quality
issue rebrand can help you gain
a new position in your audience mind
but first you need to solve the problem
that
cases that the image
diminished definition or you will be
going
through the same loop again
and uh oh my armor let me cut you off
here let me catch up here because it's
like you're just reading a wikipedia
page or something like that
he did his homework yeah you did your
homework before we get into this
i just want to say everybody noticed
omar's lighting
his hair and in the background he's
flown to the santa monica
booth in our office here and he's he's
here
you've made a major step up in your
lighting and camera game
and as well as your audio so i'm just
super appreciative
of that and i think you're just putting
the other logo therapist on
notice right now but getting into your
deck here before we like go into this
long long part because i'm afraid we're
going to be losing
our our viewership right here is tell me
what this all means in your own words
just look in the camera tell me
what the heck are you telling me right
now
well i talk about the rebrand
and the reasons for doing it
and the benefits of rebrand
in my opinion it is investment thing
because you are
fix something not
fit with your business and
yes that's all okay so the business has
grown it's changed
and when you do a rebrand you really
need to connect to the roots and kind of
address the new business needs is that
about right
yes okay beautiful what else you got for
us
yo so when you're doing these things
you're going to have to just tell this
your interpretation or a high level
summaries because
otherwise it's going to be it's going to
be dreadful to get i'm sorry to say
and did you did you actually reach out
to marty newmar you were saying
or you yeah that i'm online
you you talked to marty newmeier yes i
connect with
him and ask them about the definition of
rebranding what a nice guy well i love
that you did that you just went straight
to the source
excellent thank you mm-hmm
um okay so uh
let me tell you about the browsers
yes i love it okay
first you we should research and
understanding the current state
of the branding it is too important
okay ing is a global bank
with a strong european base have
53 employees serve around
40 million customer
and he served in 40 countries
and headquarters in amsterdam
okay what the lion stand
for baloney goes way back to ing
dodge routes the lion is
the country national symbol
and the lion symbol is
strange straight courage and
all authority and
encourage an authority yes okay and the
orange color is the national color of
netherlands
where the bank it form from
okay and the orange stand for energy and
the
vitality according to the physicology of
color
okay the ing name
stand for international netherlands
group in english
and that entire face used time new roman
typeface
and this is map uh for
the group international netherlands
group it is
uh more than companies he managed to
become ing
okay and this uh some
uh the logos uh
from the this company
uh always the companies use
the lion you know like it is the
national symbol of netherland and
most of companies use
line like i say uh
and this all of them
and the problem of current visual
identity on the logo
is this one of them is low in contrast
when when you use a dark color
with a light color
together sometimes it's be a problem we
should
choice near color or
choice both like one color
and here also it is we
we see a problem in contrast in
ing word mark
i see yes and here
we see the cut of the line it's too hard
when you want to export
it um like
you want breadboard like not 3d
extrude extrude print or something like
that
yes it is hard and expensive and this is
one of uh brand application
for the local that looks like a sad lion
he's making too much money yes
okay the logo is very complicated
and have a lot of details
and you can not use the logo on
orange background but the company
sometimes make the mistakes because
companies don't have
guide guidelines for brand identity
and even if you it is color are
reflected
we can see the shape
we can see so when it's inverted you
still it looks funny it looks like a
negative version yes yeah yeah but but
the company
have another version is oh a
negative version yeah so the company
version
use two logos like this and this
sure okay i think it's also uh
problem when you don't have guideline
because
sometimes he use run
and not good use
and it doesn't work on small sizes
like here we
can't yes it is a problem
i think the good logo can be seen in 60
by 60
pixel logo pixel size the
icon of the web
and this application icon
and also this you use in the social
media avatars
the negative version and zoom it on the
lion face
and this icon
the corporate usually use it in a lot of
places
we also we can see here we can't see
the lionful we say cutted lion
and like i say the
company usually use this in
even the headquart in the
amsterdam he used the application not
use the logo because
you know it's too hard to brand and
expensive
so also we can see a problem here
in this bank branch
also contrast and
we don't have uh some
thing standard for this bank to people
know it clearly so uh and
you can i won't share a source with you
you can't test your logo even you don't
have experience in logo up
do you want to show you or sure i don't
know what you're showing me but i'll say
yes
okay what are we looking at
okay this is a logo lab site you can
upload the logo
okay never seen this before mark
it's like a new way to see the mock-up
in different day
okay after we upload it here we
come here we see the balance
you can look to the points from here
okay and the color
when the be gracie black and the white
and the color
oh it's blind way to test your logo huh
yes that's pretty cool
it is simple for people who don't know
how to test
his logo um in small
sizes tiny medium yeah how did you find
this website
well i uh always recent
research for uh graphic design resources
and
i have a lot of sites
and i want okay i after i want to show
you how i
organization my website i find
okay and
we see the pixel ted pixelated
yes pixelated and the blur
and the s stylus slices
slice okay yeah so this is very
interesting mark i
i imagine that when we look at the
youtube algorithm
we're going to see a rewind spot right
here yeah
because we're like what's going on wait
what is this thing this is a very useful
thing for logo designers okay this is
beautiful yes it'll save a lot of time
too
yeah and this is the uh application icon
yeah this too
helpful tool the attention
yes and that's all let's uh return to
okay yeah people are saying thank you
for that
lots of things you're welcome people are
going to have stuff
yeah hey man watch the future academy
you can learn something new every day
yes
okay okay the challenge is creating new
symbol appropriate and distinctive logo
can be used in small size
and stay away from the many generic logo
of the lion
maintain the existing customer and make
it
timeless logo it does not need to be
resigned again
this is the challenge i want to to do
and after i know the problems and
challenge i conduct
research on similar cases how did they
change
we have here georgia bank
here is design we have also
lion but i think it's sea lion or
i don't know what's his name no i don't
know what it is either so
it's not a sea lion sea lion
or they have little back legs yeah okay
keep going
we see also we have a lot of details
and the
the designer he make the same shape but
simpler than the before
so okay this the first one and
we have also ing direct canada
the rebranding
it is change his name
and i see another
things in the rebranding not the logo
and yeah i make research
and this is a new primer uh
ledge identity he also
have uh lion lion and
the rebrand the redesign of logo
it make only the face
and also symbol and this primal
ages third identity in it is
24 year history and having established
the lion should stay this
design study uses eye tracking software
with focus groups reliving the most
people uh are down to the lion face
before
reading the word mark this
good information i don't have
eye tracking software or group to make
this test
you're saying omar as a young man you
don't have eye tracking software
available to you i'm a little
disappointed mark we have to cancel the
show right now
i know everyone has it come on i mean
come on
i thought you're going all in on this
episode okay so everybody just so you
understand cause sometimes
uh omar's uh pronunciation or accent you
might not get through it so let me just
make sure everybody understands this is
for
for premier league soccer club and
using some eye tracking software they
found that most people just spend the
time
looking at the face before they even
read the words i feel like we're being
set up for something here mark so let's
see
okay keep going oh wait before you do i
want to just uh read some of the
comments here
people are saying hey thanks a lot man
omar that
people are appreciating this blown
you're blowing their mind according to
praxedis and mustafa's asking can you
make
hadil redesign a new logo for egypt air
uh mustafa let me just tell you i cannot
repeat again
making your design for what no no just
don't worry i'm just talking about okay
ignore me okay okay mostafa is asking
can
you make hadil deal redesign a new logo
for egypt air and let me just tell you
i cannot make anybody do anything
especially the queen of logos a deal
okay
go ahead i like i can make people do
stuff mark
that's not possible is it no you can't
just like hey do this and make this logo
she's gonna pick what she wants to pick
and she's gonna do it when she wants to
do it
okay omar back to you keep going okay
so uh watching similar cases help you to
solve problems and
avoid mistakes okay
and i start to making mind map
oh sorry a mind map yes might not
okay all right
you guys uh omar's growing up right
before our eyes here
he's got an overhead camera now he's got
uh
studio level lighting and microphone
equipment and i like that he's
showing us this whole process really
appreciate this man he's really went
deeper in his process
yeah research alone that's that's a lot
compared to what uh we've
some of the other ones we've seen yeah
he's real stepping
really stepping up right now
so this might happen yeah yeah talk us
through what you're doing what words are
you writing
okay i can't really see it after i do
the research i
make my mind map like a promised
customer
and the market position
and the other things
it is too helpful for
understand clearly what
the company is
and how we can understand well
sorry
sorry i get
uh cal from
you pick up that phone you tell them
what you're doing right now omar whoever
calls you
yo i'm doing something right now i gotta
call you back player
and then you hang up this
phone i use it for face cam
oh i see yes okay
i i like the ing behaviors the value
and i started to write about the visual
identity uh mr
okay um the parent typeface
logo color everything i like
here i can make it speedly
that's okay i think we get the idea it's
very fascinating to see the way you
bubble these things out
it's kind of a cool artifact of your
work process
okay yeah okay
okay do you want stop to see it
or yeah i think we're ready for the next
piece okay you want to show us yeah
okay i do a skyscape
yeah that's a lot of orange on this
telescope yes
because the ing only
use orange color and i think it is
the most thing he defined
the car the bank from the other banks
yes
this is a
first page and
a second
and this okay
uh before i start sketching and i
i do a mind map and now i
uh ghost what the
sketches can be he can be
just the body but the
symbol and it can be just the face
head and or just the
face so this is probably this
can be in the sketches so
i i know i know the problem so i
don't need to
make a lot of sketches without meaning
so i work on this idea
this is uh one page from
the sketches i do i do it speedly
because
just for recording i can't draw
like this i want uh
i sketch in other places
okay i do some sketches
the body face or head
and after i do i do the sketches
i draw the chosen
sketches on small people they're not
not people
to to go to digital
okay hey omar how much time did you
spend yeah how much time did you spend
sketching
um four days or
five i'm not sure about
something like this this is one
from the sketches i make it for digital
i take the photo
and make image stand
try tries or what
yes and then
put it here and i start making golden
russia
so golden ratio is coming out already
i i make the both the golden rush sides
and then
make perfect square yeah
okay and
after that i chose the circle
and start make circles from the center
getting all your proportions set up
yes just uh okay
all right because people always want to
know how do you design logos with golden
ratio and i believe
omar showing you right now okay
i take the circles for
the sizes
and i'm look to the sketch the people
with me i don't but
behind the golden ratio and make on it
because
when i do that that's well i follow the
sketches not the golden ratio
but when i do from zero i
sk do uh
in one on full on golden ratio
not follow the sketches 100 percent
okay i think there's going to be another
section where they're going to
rewind a little bit mark yeah
i like how he's going very very detailed
with the ratio but
do you guys want to draw the golden
ratio
mark do you know how to draw it uh no
okay if i memory serves me correctly
you start with a square and then you cut
the square in half
and you take the hypotenuse of that half
and you swing that down so you're
rotating from the middle part
and the the hypotenuse the diagonal and
you rotate it down
and that becomes the rectangle that's
the perfect
golden ratio is that right omar yes
well is my webcam work
it's frozen right now uh
okay all right but i reloaded it i don't
want you to
uh disrupt your timelapse keep keep this
going we're watching
the screen right now you can just keep
trying i will hear you yeah i i
i will edit it while you're watching the
video
okay yeah all right so he's
he's building out some grid lines and
proportions based on his sketch
and when you do the golden ratio it will
start to influence the lines that you
draw
obviously so you want to make sure that
you capture
the essence of your sketch while trying
to adhere to the golden ratio
that's the idea there's a couple
different ways to do this but
i can see where he's going with this
already mark yeah it's interesting to
see
that this is being going to become the
lion
but looking at at this part point in the
process
you can't really tell can you tell yet
slightly because i've seen the the final
you have the final down there right this
guy
his sketch yeah
so i do one side to
a i don't need to make two side and
uh yeah you mirror it and then you and
join it back together sorry
okay uh
okay
let me tell you right now i've done this
before
mostly as an exercise for myself
using these golden ratio things it's
really hard to make it look good
i take two
sizes and
to make also the lock up with golden
ratio
why is it hard to make it look good with
the golden ratio chris
because when you sketch you you you're
kind of just
making shapes so that it looks right and
then when you snap everything to a grid
you have to make these decisions like do
i follow the grid or do i follow the way
it's supposed to look in my mind
and it's a balancing act and there's a
few people who do this really well
i've yet to master this because i'd
rather just draw something
i think that looks really good as
opposed to
oh it all snaps to certain some kind of
grid or ratio
i'd love to hear people in the chat talk
about this though when you guys design
an icon or a symbol how often are you
adhering to the grid of the golden ratio
or something like that
as opposed to just trying to make it
feel balanced and the way
that uh it best represents your intent
here let us know in the chat here i
make the width of the i
is the same with the logo
to get the balance between him
and after that i started to
make the corners rounded to be the same
round off the logo
okay i
copy application jamie has a funny
comment right here
sammy said golden ratio is the
definition of headache
[Laughter]
it could be most of the time for me it
has been
it's a very laborious process
yeah some other people are saying
they're in the same boat as you chris
the ratio
is fine if it works but sometimes they
just need it to work in their mind
yeah sometimes it just don't work you
guys i have to be really honest with you
now there's a balance there really is a
balance between
having the golden ratio and just keeping
everything really proportionate
and beautiful and then having this
monkey drawing that just
it just feels like garbage because
you're not following any kind of system
at all right so we gotta kind of have to
find that balance
you check the hair it looks good okay
okay
it's cameras okay you're back you're
back
almost there okay
okay let's continue
[Music]
someone's asking what type of resources
you're looking into
when you're looking at things like the
history and maybe some of the past logos
were you looking at
just digging around on google and
looking at their website
well i researched from the
company resources itself and
google yandex any search engine i
found it but
yes usually i search from google
what are you searching for what keywords
to the ing logos sources or what
no when you were doing this research and
you found the premier league and
tangerine
and what are you looking for that's what
people want to know
like we all know it's google but what
specifically are you typing in to find
are you find what can you sorry can you
be taken yeah yeah what are you
searching for
in google that yield some of the results
that you got
in terms of the premier league and what
the eye tracking stuff like where do you
find all this stuff
well um it's hard the question because
it's too complex i even can't
explain but but
i usually visit
a lot of rebranding and now a lot of
big agencies and i always look to his
work
and i know what he made or what
you should always make um
uh sorry you come if you
if i search for it you can't find it
simply
yeah i'm gonna answer the question for
you um
how do i research projects well use this
thing called
g-o-o-g-l-e and if you search for it
you'll find it
that's your answer
[Laughter]
you gotta let me answer it dude i'm
gonna answer for you but you gotta let
me talk at this point
okay okay do you see my screen uh my my
also facecam yes yeah it's working man
okay
you're good okay okay let me answer the
question
is it okay yeah okay okay if you guys
look for a couple of websites and
there's blogs that do this
they just do nothing but report on
rebrands
and you'll see the companies that get
involved and you'll they'll show you
before and after and whatever
whatever other information that you can
find so it's
probably a good thing if you're going to
be in the logo design business for you
to
be reading industry news sites like that
okay after the show errors i will drop
some links in the
description below so that you guys can
have access to the same resources that
we all have access to
all right continue on omari
yeah okay this is the legend i make it
digital
from this sketch okay
and this one it's too similar to
the first one it came also
came from this i make a square
and start draw
inside to make
it to work in small sizes it's too
important
so we not see a pixel here
but when we make it small we will see
this
it also work in 90 to
27 pixel and that's good thing i think
okay it's also uh the lion face
i make it also geometric shapes
and this logo came from
this face okay
and this one came from
this great neck action and
uh are you drawing every sketch now
not all of them i choose some of them
and they make it
digital and when you make digital
sometimes you get
new logos like this i i make
this one and i take his face
so these look more happy they are
happier happier lions
it just ate a lamb or something
yes sometimes you get um
i like this one me too i also
okay uh and this one
came from rectangle shapes
sorry think of the grid
yes can i ask the audience if you want i
show him how
i do this agreed sure go ahead
i'm the audience so go ahead
mark can you read the comment if
somebody's he wants
hey everybody in the comments omar would
like to know
what you're asking if they want to see
how you created this grid is that your
question yes
okay yes so yeah the question is out
there um
we'll see if people give it like 15
seconds
yeah jonah cut to my camera i think i'm
gonna do some asmr right now so you guys
i'm
really thirsty oh shoot just exploded on
me
oh my god watch the computers
yeah so people they do want to see that
um is that
a pretty time intensive process oh
take a long time we can we can skip it
yeah maybe if you just talk about it
are you setting this up in illustrator
and then
yes in this center
uh and then i rotated the 30 degrees
omar just do it oh you just listen to me
i have some experience running youtube
channels
when you ask and you wait for the
audience to say you could have finished
drawing the whole thing at this point
just showing yes
okay yeah okay i got this
this is the grid of the logo i do
the video and this is another version
it's too
simple it's like this
only the nose and eyes and mouth of the
lion
but also came from this
and this is another similar version
okay it is from
geometric shapes and cubes
grid and this
of all of the these okay
i won't talk about when you do a lot of
schedules
did you show us how to draw the grid yes
did i miss it yes
which one how did you draw that triangle
grid
the one that you asked everyone if they
wanted to know
yes i must be hallucinating i know it's
been a long week
i i swear to god i did three podcasts
yesterday and i did two
this morning so i'm just exhausted but
how did you draw this grid
i think that's what you asked us if we
wanted to see and we said yes and the
audience did say yes so
what happened show us how you drew this
grid okay
i'll show you thank you
stand by everybody okay what are you
drinking there chris
looks good you know what i'm drinking uh
one of our new sponsors legend energy
drinks so
i need some energy right now lauren
knows i do too
omar's sponsored apparently
[Laughter]
i also i also drink what do you guys
who's sponsoring you ing ing
[Laughter]
no it's not free no
no no it's not also no no i know we're
joking
okay i chose the polygon tool
and after i make it i not see
the rectangle i press down arrow k
and then the down arrow
yes how do you know that um
after the trial i copy
duplicate it yeah and uh
another one sorry
and flip it from oh okay okay
where are you going with this yeah and
this
and flip it again you're so clever
okay and uh after i do this
i duplicate it a lot of time
with the command d yeah yes comment yes
and also again from the
vertical yeah
yes and we select all of this
and cut or g to b group and make
30 degree and here we are i
this degree okay boom
30 degrees there you go
yes and then do you use shape builder to
draw it in yes
i i chose to show that real quick on the
other grid uh
okay the one that you just drew yeah
it's not the same thing i know i know
just just show them a little bit about
how shape builder
works like this you just draw over it
yes yes look at that you guys
omar good job man that's how you do it
people you see they're giving me a hard
time omar in the chat
you know they're giving me a hard time
the audience turns on you so quickly
mark yeah
all of a sudden they're thinking you're
a bully or something i'm a bully
chill bro just chill out let omar do his
thing it's like i'm trying to help you
guys here
and i am the audience so let's keep
going beautiful
okay
um okay people are very happy now you
see
you'll thank me later people okay
yo and i'm leaving this is it guys
omar's going to lead the show now
okay okay so you have all these uh
drawings that you've converted to vector
yes let's just take a look at this for a
second okay
there's a lot of interesting things um
i'm going to ask
our audience right now which ones they
prefer
so there's a1 a2 and
b2 c1 okay you always see one with this
c1c
i get it i get it okay okay i get it
okay so take a look at this and
of his exploration thus far do you feel
one
sticks out to you that you think is the
winner
there's one i like and i'm gonna lock it
in my mind right now
actually there are two that i like which
is your favorite guys go ahead and type
it in the chat yeah type it in
type in the exact number that you see
right now the alphanumeric combination
you got b3 a2 okay just like bingo hold
on hold on
e3 i see the uh honeycomb
lion yes really eight okay b3 and a2 let
me see a2
okay interesting huh i kind of like
that we're able to judge this part of
the process because usually it's just
the
the final product yeah because usually
our logo therapists only
vectorize one thing and then we're kind
of done at that point where sometimes in
their sketches i like what they do in
the sketch form better
so i'm going to give you guys just a
little bit more time
to see if you and i agree if i am the
audience or not mark
okay here's my two here we go you guys
ready
hands on the buzzer i like a1 a lot and
i like it more than a2
because it's much much simpler the lines
friendly
there's a lot of um you tying to the
equity that they've already built
and i i think that's a really clean
execution
of taking something and just making it
simpler
well done there the other one that i
like and
it's a toss-up right now i'm just
talking out loud is c1
and c3 they're similar c3 just has a
little bit more detail
and for whatever reason i just feel like
there's more expression in c3
and i quite like that because i get the
sense of his whiskers and his eyebrows
uh and and c1 is is more reductive so
i could live with either one of those so
for me right now i think i'm a1 and c3
it's
direct diagonal across the board there
how do how do we do mark
well compared to the audience i think
you're pretty spot on there are a lot of
a1s
and c3s yeah i think just after you said
that
i'm just kidding but there's a pretty
good variety but a lot of people they
did like the a's since that was really
close to the original
yeah so for for people who really love
the original
it's kind of nice that omar did this and
again props to you omar because a lot of
times when we do these logo redesigns
people just take the old logo and throw
it in the garbage can and it's nice to
explore
at this point you're probably talking to
your client showing them some options
and having a conversation about it
and then getting their feedback you
would move on but
cheers yeah also a lot of c3s so
very similar and that's it
look at travis travis nicholson saying i
am cristo
[Laughter]
are you really okay well i won't talk
about
how you can choose the best uh one from
a lot of sketches not only this maybe
if you you do own sketches or
logos and you want choice some of them
to
show to the client but you don't know
which one is better
so in my opinion in my
way i always ask to every
logo i made uh this question is
is this the logo is symbol is
it appropriate and uh
is this distinctive okay
when you ask this question some of
uh once you will uh go gone
sorry let me show you like this uh
the b four and the b3
it's beautiful but it is not appropriate
for ing
it is an like gaming logo or something
like that
yeah it's too digital looking right yes
yeah
and it's hard to read yes and also this
be b3 it is
like honey but i think it also looks
like gamer
logo okay and we can
make it this not appropriate
and this
it's simple but also i think not
appropriate okay
so it is a good way to
to delete some logos and
and now after you do this
three question you ask again
is this the logo solve the problem
i uh uh may research like
like this uh like img
have a problem with
printing the logo and so expensive to
print
and they don't work on small sizes
and low contrast
and also again you ask the question to
the logos uh to this and this
and you then you chose the best
one okay
in my opinion also i love the a1
sorry okay also i love it the a1s
also work in small sizes
and the clear and the perfect geometry
geometric shape but
the c1 it is uh
it is more better from the
small sizes and
cheap to print and
it is one part yes like this
three parts when every part
i didn't that's well the printing is
hard
yeah yes and i take
the logo from the application phase the
company always
use this yes and
i make it simpler and make geometry
shape with golden ratio okay
and this is the logo on white
background and the orange
i also make uh
different in um the colors i make
it's a more uh a little bit darker
uh to the to the contrast being
more strong yeah because the first one
was weak
you can't write the
on the orange color on white place in a
small size but
it is better that this color is better
okay this the pattern
it is what is this uh made out of
oh parts of the logo yes icon this the
logo
do you see it here i'm having a hard
time seeing
it but i see parts of it is it like half
of it reflected
no no reflected yes reflected logo yes
this that one it's a cool pattern
regardless oh i see the lion's face a
little bit you see it
jonah yeah all right i'll keep stirring
here's the eyes
yeah oh it has a kind of very regal
quality to it
like very high end okay keep going okay
uh this is some uh brand application
this is uh
clock also from the logo
like that's what yes nice
sorry let me just read a comment of
siberia waheed is saying today is so
inform
informative just sharing some of the
affection there keep going okay
you can take a drink it's fine okay i
will take you
drink man enjoy
i need to be relaxed and the first i
was confused i don't know why because
yeah
okay let's continue and this is the
other
one also from the parent
also you can read the time this 12 and
this three
and here one two okay sorry
uh one yeah yeah
one two three it's so easy to read yes
yes this be a nice gift to tell you when
to pay your bills
i like the orange background with the
white it's simpler
whereas the white with the orange on top
of it seems a little complicated i like
that morph
just for the pattern itself but there's
something about the
the white to orange ratio of the right
design that just feels more
pleasing to me yes
okay do you want to keep going
yes please okay and dustin reed i am
ready for the weekend for sure come on
the is also the make from the parent
yeah nice yeah the tape okay
again mark is it me or is it uh is is
this universal
i like the orange tape with the white
print versus the white tape with the
orange print it just
feels different yeah i think the first
looks better
yeah it'd match a lot more different
things
but i like how the style looks very like
luxurious
mm-hmm yes you get that tory burch vibe
exactly yeah
okay there's a brand guideline
okay okay
at this step in there i use that do your
thing is that their tagline
yeah it is the slogan of ing
okay okay
uh you see the
um okay
later on yes it's better than the last
time
it is yeah it's clear and not have
so much yeah
and this is the credit card
let me zoom to see the details
i like the lighting on there
okay yeah
lanyard yes
[Music]
nice
and this the poster
do you think do you think
the system yes all right
this is the business card and the upper
right
piece of collateral looks like you've
got some kind of spot varnish so it's
kind of a sheen effect to the background
is that the idea there or is it just a
gradient
envelope here yeah is that is that a
metallic
or spot varnish no it's not metallic no
it's a
green ingredient yeah yes okay cool
okay yeah yeah it is from the back and
the application
okay inevitably people always ask what's
the mock-up source
where did you find these mock-ups don't
say google
no no i was okay remind me i will share
the
sources in the end yeah and then yeah
okay i will sure okay
this also
and this we got
and this is i do the it's not smoke up
it's a real picture uh
oh you printed all the stuff out yes can
can
some
and cut it and do it like this
put it on card stock and everything yes
wow
and you even made a mug right
the business car
okay uh this is the from the side
it's not so much cool but it helps with
these photos yourself
yes what camera no it's
by phone it is samsung sg3
yeah sponsor shout
yeah you can't even say for a mobile
phone i you that just described it
no no no it's not you it's mark i'm just
giving mark our time
mark's like this is pretty good for like
a cheaper mobile phone
i think these are good photos and a lot
of times people say oh chris i love your
photos
what kind of camera are you using it my
iphone you have to learn how to
to light and compose and it's a little
harder to to shoot these things with
your mobile phone
i like that you actually shot these and
naturally built the mock-ups it takes a
lot of extra energy and effort to make
these things
but then it gives you interesting camera
angles and ways to change the lighting
that nobody else can have
and i think that's really cool yes how
did you make the the
the bag the bag
only the bag no not photoshop i bring
the bag but only orange
he don't uh there was anything and i
bought the logo in the photoshop only
yeah that's what i meant what's the step
back it's real
no
because i see the white print on it that
would be too expensive for you to do
yeah so i assume that part was
photoshopped yes i understand
yeah do you have the color correct the
bag to get it to be the right orange
yes yes yeah very nice yeah people are
saying the ones that you made are the
best ones
yeah they're pretty nice i have to say
pretty nice
i think okay uh this awesome
mockup i do by myself okay uh-huh
i usually i prefer get
a high quality image and do my
own mock-up i i will show you if you
want
how i did this quickly okay you want to
see
it depends how much more of this
presentation is
not a lot okay i i don't image and it
did the color
to be red to orange and
after that i bring the logo okay and
make it
in the right size and make a little bit
perspective
to okay and uh start make bevel
and drop shadow and try to make the same
thing
on the left the original one and you're
comparing it to it to make it match
nice and after that i deleted that bag
okay and you clean it up
okay yes and i copied the logo here
and also you did this yep healing spot
healing brush there
yes yes normal brush and look at this
perspective i yep command drag
yes i think it's a cut cutter shift
yes command shift command for mac
control for pc
yes
you're basically corner pinning it in
there so it matches the perspective
yes this easy way and so
good and easy everybody can do
his mock-up by himself i think it's
better than
the you download uh
mockup because sometimes you don't find
the thing you have in your mind and this
looks more
reality yeah very nice okay
okay i want to read a comment here from
the super chats uh
i just don't have to say your name but i
really appreciate you it's prosex
i think he's saying we've taken a third
of your courses and ordered pocketful of
dough yesterday thank you for your
dedication so much time to other success
hashtag lifechange thank you very much
and there's one more here
from wiktrix media just appreciating the
value
giving us the muscle arm
thank you so much appreciate that all
right
okay what else we got
um okay now i will share the resources
oh it's really yeah okay okay all right
what everybody is
asking for yeah okay
i start to use
uh search engine it's not search engine
browser i think uh it's uh
better to use what it is
browser
uh this one
oh microsoft yeah
the microsoft edge browser okay yes yes
okay keep going
we can make collection for the site
i have like time management photos
and my own website
and uh okay here i have um
mockup3 it's markup3 yes
it's good okay site for mockup a graphic
pier can you do me a favor can you just
click and open new tabs as you talk
about them because
okay so hard to see yeah thanks okay
yeah yeah yeah yeah and now just take us
to your tabs
okay okay more customers mock-ups
yes okay are these free or are these uh
pages yes it's all
free all free yes the world's a good
place and
sometimes right there was a premiere
and free i don't know but but
no no no i there was uh something free
and
something uh paid i say
this this uh so good site but
something uh there was uh paid
content not only what's this one called
it is the graphic pier
graphic parrot thank you jonah okay
what's the next one
okay i know pixed in class
it's famous everybody take from here
everybody uses these things right
yes at the mockup slash design.com
mockups design.com i do not know this
one that's a good looking
coffee cup there yes that's a good look
oh so good
side i look i take it from this oh
there's your tape
yes yeah okay
yeah more cup for free
mock-ups for free i like them
as long as they don't charge
it's also good side and
zippypixels.com zippypixels.com
yes okay that's another one i do not
know of very nice
yeah mark i got an idea i got an idea
maybe at some point when we're filthy
stinking rich as the future
some point in the near future we can
just hire 3d artists and
and photoshop people to build the best
mock-ups and just give it away to our
community for free
that would be amazing right the best
models library somebody full time
and just ask people uh what mock-ups do
you want this week and they'll just make
them all day long
for us would that excite you guys
let's ask them i would do it if i was a
designer and i'm making this stuff i
mean
right we've got to help the community
out
the idea you can hire me yeah we will
call it
the best mockups.com
thebestmockups.com that's that's don't
don't anybody take that url
okay thanks for sharing those resources
i know people
truly appreciate that and this is really
a community about sharing and giving and
for all the people who hung out to the
very end
we won't put those in the descriptions
below make you watch this video to the
very end
okay what else we got okay
i think uh that's all okay
beautiful so very nice yeah good job man
good job good job man
all right all right now i i do want to
address something
there's some cyber bullies out there
they're like you know elmar needs to
work on his presentation skills look
this is only his second time on our
channel
and i think we as designers need to just
give everybody a little bit of a break
because
english is not his first language you're
from turkey right
no i'm from iraq but i live in turkey
yes
okay so how many different languages do
you speak
uh well i speak my mother language is
arabic and i speak
turkish well and i am intermediate uh
in english yes so look it's a lot of
languages
languages okay he speaks three languages
i struggle with just one
engrish okay i still struggle with it so
guys
just relax it's about to work after all
and i i like that uh
this go around omar has gone much deeper
into research he's he's done a really
good job of documenting
his process and kudos to you and just
for having
the the guts to just present your work
and and let the world to see it
and there's a lot of keyboard warriors
couch surfers out there who think that
they can do better well i encourage you
to do better and show us all right it's
not so easy yeah okay so
it's a part of the show now where i get
to ask you guys
which logo you prefer so here we are
the original on the left for ing which
is a dutch company
and it's in 40 countries ing stands for
something international something right
okay whatever you love me hanging there
bro
that's okay don't worry about it you
prefer the one on the left which is the
original with the lion
or do you prefer omar's version this
revised
rebrand that he's been able to put
together for us
so let us know do you prefer option one
the original or option two
the revise and i see that now omar
has pulled up something on behance and
you're showing your entire process there
or
i will publish i will publish it right
now to people see it with high quality
beautiful yes okay so if you guys want
to see the finished product he's
publishing it literally right now
publishes right now you can see that
right now so you guys can go check them
out on behance
and if you want to find out more about
omar and what he's doing i highly
encourage you if you like this episode
reach out to this young man he's got a
lot of talent and potential here
i'm i'm sure he's open for reasonable
commissions if you need help with your
logo
you don't have to be ing to hire him i
think he just need to bring some
m-o-n-e-y make a deal
some money okay this is omar salman he's
uh residing in ankara turkey right now
he's iraqi but
i think that's it mark we gotta get out
of here yes i gotta eat
i'm hungry i'm hangry yeah thanks
everybody for your comments i think a
lot of people
like the revised version of that and
good job omar yes so now before i say
goodbye
and i'm doing this on purpose so jonah
can get the music ready
okay because he's gonna trigger this
right now i also want to say
thank you very much to travis nicholson
who also super chatted us
he says i've been shamelessly following
the future without supporting for so
long
shame about you i'm just kidding thanks
for following us and might as well start
now
really appreciate it travis and i hope
to see you guys real soon like in a
couple hours because we're back
live streaming we're going to be talking
about tick-tock my favorite platform
tock all right that's it let's get out
of here jonah if you guys uh made it all
the way to end thank you very much
don't forget to like comment and
subscribe hit the bell for notifications
that's been it for us for this morning i
guess
on behalf of mark and jonah i also want
to thank omar omer thank you very much
for doing this
next time buddy
there he goes